10 dollars la chapk en peau de la fin ça
serait dommage de s'en priver d'autant
qu'avec ça sur la tête le premier
touriste venu devient comme par
enchantement un grand spécialiste de la
Russie Jean-Marie Le Pen n'échappe pas à
la règle le chef du Front national est
venu à Moscou à l'invitation de son ami
Vladimir jérynowski qui fête demain
c'est 25 ans de mariage
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui n'a plus froid aux
oreilles peut donc désormais nous dire
tout le bien qu'il pense du leader de
l'extrême droite russe nous sommes dans
un pays qui n'a pas l'habitude du débat
démocratique qui est obligé d'en faire
l'apprentissage alors quelquefois ça
peut être un peu brute de décoffrage
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire quand
un militant ultra-nationaliste demande à
gérinoski qu'elle serait leur attitude
commune en cas de Troisième Guerre
mondiale la réponse traduite à la
perfection ce qui unissait deux hommes
les Français digérénoski environ leurs
immigrés se battre à leur place et nous
on enverra nos tchétchène
[Musique]
afin d'être crédible elle doit rayonner
à l'étranger et c'est là l'affaire d'un
autre de ses conseillers Aymeric soprane
il parcourt le monde et joue un rôle de
missionnaire pour le parti
notamment en Russie à Moscou où il se
rend très régulièrement
à Moscou Aymeric Chopra dès le FN
comptent aujourd'hui de solides alliés
[Musique]
il retrouve ce soir-là un oligarque
russe qui serait très proche de Vladimir
Poutine un multimillionnaire
Constantin Malo fayev les deux hommes
sont sur la même longueur d'onde ils
partagent aussi une vision très précise
de leur pays respectifs
entre la Russie et la France et vive la
France
briefing
certains vont se dire il vient chercher
de l'argent pour le Front national
peut-être d'abord on ne cherche pas
je vais vous dire une chose lui et moi
nous sommes deux patriotes oui c'est un
patriote
russe moi un patriote français et nous
pensons de la même façon nous défendons
un certain nombre de valeurs aussi c'est
une alliance
pour le oui on défend les valeurs
chrétiennes ça c'est clair moi je
j'assume le fait que dans mon combat
politique à l'idée que la France est un
pays d'identité chrétienne il y a
aujourd'hui une grande nation une seule
qui au plus haut niveau de l'État avec
Vladimir Poutine défend les valeurs
traditionnelles qui refusent le digt des
LGBT c'est pas un hasard s'il est Femen
et ces phénomènes s'attaquent à la
Russie s'attaque au Front national
s'attaque à tous ces milieux il
s'attaque à nous parce que nous sommes
les défenseurs d'un certain nombre de
valeurs naturelles
[Musique]
c'est la première poignée de main
officielle entre Marine Le Pen et le
président russe une heure et demie à
discuté de la lutte contre le terrorisme
ou encore de la situation en Syrie
Vladimir Poutine ne le cache pas c'est
elle sa favorite parmi tous les
candidats à l'Élysée mais il se défend
de tout ingérence dans la campagne
présidentielle française
je sais qu'actuellement il y a des
élections en France
nous ne voulons d'aucune manière
influencer le cours des événements mais
nous nous accordons le droit de
rencontrer tous les représentants du
pouvoir politique tout comme les
États-Unis et les partenaires européens
le font
[Musique]
juste une dernière question le Front
National a du mal à trouver des
financements est-ce que vous nous
confirmez ce soir que c'est une banque
russe qui finance aujourd'hui en partie
le Front national un près de 9 millions
d'euros c'est ça
nous avons fait un prêt nous avons été
obligé d'aller à l'étranger parce que
pas une seule banque française ne veut
nous prêter alors écoutez si demain une
banque française rachète notre prêt
immédiatement je signe immédiatement
voici celui qui au sein du FN a signé le
contrat et il admet le parti a fait
jouer ses connaissances pour obtenir ce
prêt nous avons un contact avec
quelqu'un que nous connaissons bien qui
a des relations en Russie depuis très
longtemps très très longtemps et qui
nous dit allez voir cette banque vous
serez bien reçu par eux ils vont vous
écouter s'ils veulent bien vous faire ce
prêt et bien ils le feront la banque la
First check Russian Bank une présence
discrète à Moscou un petit établissement
financier qui hormis ce prêt we FN n'a
pas d'activité en France ni de bureau
[Musique]
sommes reconnaissants envers vous de
votre position bien équilibrée et basé
sur l'analyse attentive de faits réels
votre position sur les événements en
train de se produire en Ukraine et juste
[Musique]
première mesure que je prendrais
vis-à-vis de la Russie ce serait de
réfléchir à la levée des sanctions bien
entendu car j'ai toujours été opposé à
ces sanctions que je trouvais en même
temps profondément injuste et tout à
fait contre-productive la Russie est un
pays européen en réalité la Russie s'est
tournée vers la Chine parce que l'Union
européenne ne cesse de lui claquer la
porte née on a traité la Russie comme
une ennemi alors que tout devrait nous
pousser à avoir des relations au sein de
l'Europe avec la Russie
alors c'est bien d'aller à
Saint-Pétersbourg etc mais on a le
sentiment si vous voulez que tout ça ne
sert à rien il y a une forme de
réchauffement mais pour aller où moi par
exemple je souhaite que l'on puisse
intégrer la Russie à l'OTAN
[Musique]
on peut avoir à son égard énormément de
réserve on peut s'en méfier on peut le
considérer brutal on peut tous qu'on
veut mais on ne peut pas je veux dire
traiter par le mépris le dirigeant
politique qu'il est parce que il a
réussi à faire de la Russie à nouveau un
acteur de premier plan à nouveau un pays
qui tient la route sur le plan
économique donc moi j'essaye d'être
objective maintenant c'est sûr que ce
qui s'est passé là la guerre en Ukraine
inadmissible et est insupportable et à
mon avis un pardonnable mais je pense
surtout que c'est une gigantesque
erreur de sa part
[Musique]